Each of these things can cause more errors. The answer is all of them marked.
The poll being taken before the election can certainly affect its accuracy because
sentiments shift over time.
Some being under-represented in the samples.
Certainly, if voters who favor one candidate versus another are under or over-represented
that will change the results.
Similarly if we tend to have people who are more likely to vote
represented the same as those who are less likely to vote,
they're not being over-represented enough.
So these two things ideally should be linked.
And in a well-designed poll, they try to do this although it's hard to do this perfectly.
And responses that differ of course will cause additional error.